last time out at boston four to third
three earned seven strikeouts would have
loved to have seen him pitch deeper
didn't walk anyone he likes to go away
from the right-hander so he'll throw
predominantly the fan spawn is change up
occasionally he'll throw some some curve
balls at you but i think more than
anything he just likes to throw the fan
small and change up try to get you to
roll over on a change up outside
lines one to right and right there is
jose rojas and that's how the ball game
starts cannon
with a very hard hit ball but into the
glove of ross so here's matt chapman 222
the average for chapman five homers and
19 rbis now here's the three one pitch
and chapman takes inside and these have
their first base winner so matt walks
and that'll bring up loriano top of the
first no score in the 2-2 fish de
lariano is a line smash into center for
a base hit chapman turns at second holes
there as lagarres plays it back
and these have their first hit well it's
nice to see an ace hitter get a two
strike base hit solidly hit up the
middle or lift it over the middle of the
plate and loriano right back up the
middle hard
count is two and two next pitch and he
got him right there curveball struck him
out
and that is how the inning will end
so the a's fail to score and we're
headed to the bottom of the first james
capillion another great name he's a
local product irvine beckman high school
ucla
all the way back from tommy john
recently made his major league debut as
a starting pitcher he deals with
iglesias who goes to work
first pitch swinging into center field
loriano
over to his left puts it away so it's a
great story with caprilian he does have
a lot of support up above that first
base dugout and gooby it's taken him a
long time to get to this point two and
two to ohtani
he hits one very high in the air left
center field cannon going back
now ramon laureato is going to call him
off on the warning track in front of the
390-foot side and he makes the catch for
the second half nick's sign relief from
his dad
that's one time ohtani makes it out
jared walsh now
bouncing ball he found a hole into right
field rendon takes a turn at second
stops right there
so jared walsh he's had three hits twice
this year he's had four hits twice maybe
it's one of those nights tonight
now the 1-1 murphy waits he swings and
rips one to left down the line for a
base and that's going to the wall he is
turning at first and murphy will cruise
into second with a double and these have
their second hit so double number eight
on the year for murphy utira goes way
inside and sean murphy is just so quick
94 heater on the inside part of the
blade and he turned on it top spin kept
it in play instead of going into the
bullpen here's the 3-2 and that one is
chased and missed elevated the fastball
got him swinging struck him out and the
inning is over here are strikeouts in
the inning for quintana three so far now
the three suit fish legaris of
right-handed hitter caprilian ready
delivers and here it is and a fastball
swung on fly ball right field and foul
territory long run for piscotty and he
makes a great sliding catch and holds on
excellent play by stephen racing into
fowlet territory winding up on the track
and then sliding right in front of the
side wall down there makes a great play
for the second out piscotty what a
tremendous play never once looked up to
see how close he was to the sidewalk
that's what a pitcher loves spark got a
couple of fastballs in the first setting
and he hit one the other way slight
hesitation and the pitch comes up and
him with the fastball cannon may have
gotten all this one lageris is back to
the wall near the garden and gone
unloads on quintana his ninth of the
year
and it's one nothing oakland you talk
about muscling a fastball now if it's a
98 mile our fastball he probably doesn't
do it but this fastball at 90 and he
just muscled it up
into right field toward the gap it goes
rojas on the run won't make the play he
will plan on a hop
katsey is going to take a chance here's
the relay toward the plate the relay
[Applause]
gunned down at home plate as the base
runner olson he tried to score all the
way from
first base on that one and the angels
throw him out he's got some pretty good
power in his back he can drive the ball
here's the pitch that's a shot that's
well hit out in center field and that
one is out of here
a line drive home run
it got over the wall out there
just to the left of dead center and uh
homer by iglesias quickly ties up this
spa game at one and he didn't take long
to get around that bases either he
drives that one out that's a big part of
the yard for iglesias
fourth home run these two have fun
together always talking now here's the
2-2 he's ready he turns he delivers in
is swung on a fly ball
right center field a trio of a's pinder
going out makes an unbelievable catch
you wouldn't believe the play that he
made pinder racing out from second base
and lauriana coming in from center
biscotti from right and over the
shoulder acrobatic and somehow able to
find the ball cradles it right around
his chest and then tumbles over and
holds on with a phenomenal catch by chad
pinder ending the fifth inning now these
have the bases loaded and murphy is
coming up
myers drives one towards center
laguerras turns around and bangs off the
wall
he picks it up one run scores two runs
are gonna score murphy comes through
with his second double it's a two-run
double and the a's lead to three to one
dead center field over the head of
legaures and the is get the big hit
they've been looking for no you think of
caprilion in his hometown working into
the sixth inning he's pitched great
inside corner strike three call good
pitch nine strikeouts
he's up to 99 pitches so this is going
to be his last inning and he'd like to
finish it with a flourish
here comes the pitch this is driven into
center field this ball's hit well out in
left center and it's out of here
that's a home run for walsh the angels
have hit a couple home runs against
caprilian dad was saddened and then son
was taken out of the game and the mates
were waiting the family former teammates
cheered juan legaris has flied out to
center twice
here's the pitch that's a shot down the
right side that's a fair ball and that
is going to give the angels the lead the
ball gets away from piscotty it's
rolling around headed into third bases
lagarus and they'll hold them there he
gets a triple though and the angels are
on top it's 4-3 right-hand batter
against the right-hand pitcher
roll to the right side he shot it
through
that was a fast ball out over the plate
here's the throw
he's got two doubles to make that two
outfield assists
chad with two hits and a run scored both
of his hits going to the opposite field
hits the chad a fastball and he strokes
it dead center on the run legaures at
the wall and out of room
chad pinder
picks the team up and carries them
around on a three-run homer and the azer
back in front six to four first pitch to
rendon he swings and he slammed at the
left center field back on it as loriano
at the wall jumps at the wall he's got
it
loriado pulls it back and saves the day
rendon with a blast to left center it
was out of the ballpark until laureano
brought it back
memories continue for laureano at angel
stadium the big catch center and a
perfect night at the plate he is three
for three and that one is hit high and
deep and
that baby's gone have a night laser
remote seven four a's in the ninth
and lowry hits one high and deep and
that baby's gone and that's their fourth
long ball tonight and it's 8-4 in favor
of the a's in the ninth
and the pitch to fletcher is swung on a
ground ball left side spirit chapman
goes to second relay by pin you're in
time for a double play and what a way to
end it and really a wild ball game
tonight won by the a's in anaheim